[Music]
one item from the shrine which item
would you pick and why mine would be the
uh there is a they recreated the garage
the section of the garage and the door
that Tatum is crushed in and you only
see it a little bit in like the top
corner of a few frames but it was my
favorite problem that's it that's a good
one solid Choice yeah I'd go with
Billy's knife I just I want the OG yeah
I'd go with one of the robes yeah damn
robe smart I would pick the TV because
Stu's dead yeah
big broad question here and now you
could talk spoilers our viewers have
been warned there's Graphics all over
this video do not watch it if you
haven't seen the movie go watch it and
then come push play and it'll be right
here for you so of all the scenes in
this movie going into filming which did
you think would be the most challenging
to film and then ultimately was that
indeed the most challenging or did
something else Catch You by surprise
Subway
yeah Subway in the ladder sequence too I
think it was because because that came
and went a little bit and came back yeah
guys the killer monologue was oh yeah
there was
um I mean yeah
weekends were consumed with just
blocking blocking talking about how to
block that scene and and make sure that
it had that it had enough I mean
obviously you didn't scream five most of
that takes place in the kitchen so there
are only so many things you can do you
can do with it we wanted to make sure
that with this one there was a lot of
movements and that there were a lot of
gear shifts and changes within that
scene and so figuring out where people
go why they're why they end up where
they end up at what point in the
monologue those those changes happen and
then just shot shot selection wise it's
it's five characters that become six
characters we weren't we ran through the
alphabet three times in terms of the
number of setups that we did I think it
was like in colors on the ice setups
um so it was just we all cheered when we
were finally done with 87d it was like
this moment we're like holy we I
can't believe we survived we made it out
of this scene also just on a like a
performance level because like Dermot
has to carry so much of that scene in
terms of like Exposition and you know
lyanna and Jack too and then Sam and
Tara have to stay emotionally grounded
the whole time and I think you know like
hats off to all of them because they
gave us so much to work with in the edit
that even after going through it all
there then we got to the edit and I
remember Jr editor was like
how do we want to do this scene like
literally stayed up crying about how to
cut that sequence you know there's like
a million versions of that scene that we
could have ended up with and so nice
hearing you guys go like the dialogue
character-driven route especially when
you would think um in a movie like this
something that's more action-heavy with
blood would be the most difficult thing
but that's that's some of the most
important stuff that gives everything
else weight totally yeah I think the
action stuff is like really in our in
our in our blood and our bones I think
that you know we did like a lot of
really Scrappy action stuff ourselves
like kind of you know when we first
started making stuff together so I think
that there was like that muscle flexes
really easily for us I think it's really
about like an ensemble scene where you
want to give everyone a moment and it's
also a lot of page count and it's really
valuable like that's everyone sort of
waits for that big reveal that big
monologue right it's like such a coveted
moment in a Scream movie and wanting to
make sure that it felt alive and
activated the whole time going back to
what you just mentioned about it Scrappy
filmmaking even when you are making a
Paramount Scream movie every once in a
while things don't go to planning you
have to get Scrappy is there any example
of something in this film where you had
to approach it that way when some folks
out there might be like oh big budget
Studio horror movie I feel like on some
level all of it like to be totally
honest like we we talked a lot about how
like this feels like a really big movie
but for us it doesn't feel much
different than like when we did ready or
not for you know a fifth of the budget
or whatever but it's and part of that is
intentional because I think there's an
energy that comes with that and I think
we love that making it feel kind of
Scrappy making it feel pressure is a
good thing yeah and I think the big
difference is is that on this one you
know our department heads have more to
work with they have more you know
resources so there's a lot like the
subway build was gigantic you know but
uh and then we're only in it for like
three days yeah right so you think like
oh that's a long will you spend a week
or a week in a set like that it was
three you know three three days of
shooting and then we were we were gone
Gail Gales was Gail's apartment
you know Courtney was up there for just
a a very specific chunk of time night
shoots
um in a practical location that's
Windows 360 degrees so can't control the
light you have to get what you can get
while the sun is still down and it was
it was a race we only had six hours yeah
yeah and shooting nights in Canada in
the summer so there's not a lot of night
time
see that sequence there's a lot I love
in the movie that sequence in particular
might be one of the most 10 scenes I've
ever seen in a Scream movie one because
the action is very well choreographed
but also you use the emotional
connection to Gail so incredibly well
where all of a sudden I realized like
like I was grabbing the armrest of my
seat far harder than I had the entire
movie it's really something else
of everything I saw in this film what
would you say change the most from
script to screen that third that third
act yeah yeah
um there was a it was and it was I think
it was written intentionally loose um
because there was so much work it was it
was all happening so fast and there was
so much work we just knew we were gonna
have to do in prep and a lot of that
work was going to be location specific
that was um it was a warehouse for a
minute uh it was a warehouse with with
movie memorabilia in it not not true not
true crime stuff or was a mix of things
yeah there was no no fan film component
um and and so we we were scouting in our
production designer Michelle liberte
came to us and was like there's this
badass old theater in Montreal that we
can take over and we can make it
whatever we want and that that was sort
of the seed that then became what that
set piece like what that location
really is because there was also switch
on what the killers in the motive was
that also changed during the course of
it and a lot of this is you know credits
A Guy and Jamie like we got the script
early they were still like in the
process of working it all out and then
they were able to like every little idea
that came to them they were able to take
it you know take that seat and plant it
and grow something really awesome but it
was a it was an ongoing process it was
like a real time like yeah guys we're at
the theater like what if this happened
oh great really you know I mean it was
really and then they flew up there
remember yeah the guy and Jimmy they did
the walk through to do a whole walk
through to be able to then take the
ideas that they had had and put in the
warehouse to be like well where could we
play this out in this theater oh I have
so many questions big props to that
location scout that makes such a huge
difference in this film
if it was different motives but was it
always the same three killers was the
plan always to make the killers in this
movie Richie's family no
found that in development though yeah
that was working on it yeah and it was
and that was born of wanting
um at the end I think that we knew that
the movie up to that big reveal was
gonna be like pretty bombastic and
pretty pretty crazy in terms of its
energy level and I think we just felt
like the the motive at the end of the
day needed to be something super Primal
and really simple and relatable and like
Revenge you know the love and the loss
of a child that it's also for as much as
like the core 4 story is about family
that the villain story is also about
family it just felt like this really
neat and tidy kind of symmetrical
handoff of that theme and and at the end
of the day it just it doesn't it doesn't
have to be about some larger Grand kind
of meta thing like it can just be simply
about about right and it shows you how
things snowball a little bit too right
because it started with the production
design and finding a theater and then
being like Oh we could put fan films up
on and see what was going on and then
we're like well if it's Richie's family
maybe Richie was making these fan films
because he loves the stab movie so much
and then we reached out to Jack Quade
and Jack had this this treasure troll
I'm like talking directly to camera when
he was younger and we're like oh this is
perfect now now oh now it's all tied
together and the emotionality is all
there and then that unit and theme of
family is there at the end it works
really well it pairs with all the other
character revolute Evolutions quite well
too so I'm not going to press you on the
other killer that came before Richie's
family but you did also say the mo the
motive had changed so the motive in
terms of the three of them and why they
were doing this there's a misdirect on
the motive the whole time you know and
when I you know I remember when we were
reading earlier drafts of the script
it's you know us Guy and Jamie everybody
agreed that like something wasn't quite
clicking but we weren't really sure what
that was and I I remember when they were
like we figured it out that's the motive
that gets you there and then that's part
of the motive is let's do a misdirect
it's all all about this and we'll start
these rumors about Sam and we'll think
it's about like and you think yeah you
think it's about this online mob
mentality and the that we all talk
about in pop culture in real life now
and then to have like there's like one
of my favorite moments is when German is
just like yeah whatever you know you're
like that who gives a that's
yeah this and you go oh this is
about you know this is about something
real this is about family and there I
know one of the one of the scenes that
like never changed much from the early
edit was when that hit Sam and Terra and
you go oh this is not like
some big you know like if we're not
having like a we're not having like a
big let's talk about big Grand things
it's just you killed our kid
it's that Quinn line where you killed
our brother you and you're
like
I'm sorry what like the the bottom kind
of falls out of the scene in that moment
Nancy Loomis too
pure revenge and that's it and two we
were like we very much were aware and
wanted to be living in the in the the
sort of direct lineage of Two And
there's a lot that we that we love about
that movie that we wanted to make sure
we were
um borrowing in very specific ways in
this it's a very random connection
question that has nothing to do with
Scream but we're the Jurassic Park Vibes
and the bodega scene deliberate yes
my two favorite franchises
I love it um I did want to ask a little
bit about the Sydney of it all and I I
guess I have to start with was the plan
ever to have her included in this
narrative and if that was the case how
did you go about pivoting and writing a
story that didn't have her there in the
flesh you know it's
we found out early on in pre-production
that Nev wasn't going to do this one and
there had been drafts and ideas and
stuff going around but the the thing
that guy and Jamie did that was like so
great and really helped us is that they
had created this the structure of the
movie that I don't think ever really
changed much in solid yeah it was really
like stuff like the motives and this
that it that shifted but the movie from
kind of a bird's eye view didn't change
that much and I think one of the things
obviously like we were super bummed when
I wasn't going to do it and the the
thing that we immediately went to was
like okay if if we're not doing this
with Nev again
we have we have to make sure that you
fall in love with these characters the
way that we all fell in love with you
know Sydney and Gala Dewey and so we
took that responsibility really really
seriously and made sure that you know if
we do our job right you leave this movie
going oh I love the core four and I want
I want their journey to continue the
same way that we all want Sydney and
Gail and Dewey to continue and at the
end of the day I think there's no
success in that department I couldn't
believe that yeah we don't think there's
any way to make a screen movie that
doesn't have an echo of that character
right it's it's she's she means so much
to the franchise and to us and it was
important that she'd be present sort of
spiritually in the movie but that the
only way to really honor her was to also
make a great screen movie and and do
those characters do the core four
Justice I don't know how you guys feel
about this but part of my take on that
matter too is we've watched these people
fight for their life
happily ever after for so many years now
if you never let anybody experience that
happily ever after what's that fight
gonna mean anymore yeah yeah no no I
think about that a lot
um going back to the killers briefly
when you're casting Killers like in
particular I guess Jack and lyanna what
do you look for in the two of them that
says to you that they can handle both
sides of that divide without you know
like tipping the scale too far too soon
so when we're casting those roles
specifically
they they read sides for their character
and then everyone that we cast read a
monologue a ghost face monologue and
part of it is to throw the cast off the
scent because we can't you can't cast
The Killer specifically because if
you're auditioning multiple people then
multiple people know the know the ending
of the movie and it just it becomes a
whole it becomes a whole Tangled mess so
everybody
Josh lyanna
Jack Devin and everybody else who gave
great auditions but wasn't in the movie
they all they all read Amber's monologue
from Scream five and in addition to
their scenes and by the way there are
some jobs
yeah so awesome so it was
incredible yeah but it's um but there's
so many I think one of the good one of
the things you you learn if you love
these movies that those monologues have
so many there are so many like weird
little performance opportunities inside
of them and you get a you get a really
quick sense of of someone's range when
you give them one of those and and if
the and they know the movies like you
know lyanna Jack like they're such fans
of the screen movies they knew exactly
what to do with with that that's what
those pieces work yeah and I also
remember like the honest specifically
like she cut loose on the audition and
it was like you know it's it's weird
because it's not a version that you see
in the movie necessarily but kind of
what you're saying you see the range and
also of just the the like the freedom to
be like oh I can go crate I can
do this and you go like oh that's an
actor who like is is giving it their own
it's totally Fairless yeah and one of
the best parts of all of that was they
didn't get the third Act of the script
at all so they're in their costume
fittings and they tried on their
costumes and then we came in and there's
like one more thing you have to try on
and then we brought out the ghost face
robe and a mask so they could try it on
for the first time that's how they found
out yeah
oh I have so many questions
we also have amazing videos of these
moments of them finding out I remember
you saying about uh telling Jack and
like an expression on his face when he
found out so did you tell this cast the
identity of Ghostface at the same time
you did the Scream 5 cast
like in terms of the production schedule
and everything did everyone find out no
there was less there was less secrecy on
this one with the original yeah yeah
um
honestly Tony Tony though didn't know
until he saw the movie which is right
Tony was like living she's like living
on a very tiny little island for the
whole time we also have a video of him
before he walked into his first
screening of it we were like who who is
your who's your ghost face prediction
wildly off it was busy talking to Tony
and he he was trying to convince me that
he had never seen any of the Scream
movies and he didn't know anything and I
couldn't tell if he was no you know
I kept not believing him and then also
telling him like you're dead I know
you're dead
I know you're dead one thing that was
that was making me curious with the
three of them because I don't think you
say it in the movie what what are their
real names what I'm sorry I think we
have to go right yeah
we've had this debate a lot where are
the fake names or the real names yeah
it's uh and we have an internal debate
with us I think we've decided I think
we've decided to correct me if I'm wrong
that Richie's Richie curses a pseudonym
and Bailey is also a pseudonym that the
real name is whoever they were in the
midwest yeah
yeah but then there's an issue with that
tracking with him transferring to the
and yeah NYPD yeah oh my head is
exploding yeah yeah it does yeah
this this is gonna mess up my little uh
timeline here but given the the idea of
bringing up their names what about the
name of the movie itself was there
there's some sort of internal debate in
terms of going I don't know like Scream
Six with six written out not in Roman
numerals was it ever going to be scream
2023 we had a million names I mean every
name you can think of we went through a
bunch of stuff and when it landed on
screen Roman numerals I think we all
just sort of embraced it because it lets
the audience know that we know that this
is Scream Roman numeral six this isn't
you know the last one on the screen just
you know there's like a classiness and
calling it just scream on this one it's
like hey we're in New York uh it's
screamed with Roman numerals it's absurd
it's absurd like it's balls of the wall
let's go have fun you know yeah and it
looks nice right it's like it kind of
serves both purposes okay I remember my
third act question now so you were just
telling us about the the reveal via like
here's your ghost face costume so Dermot
knew he was the killer when he was first
cast but Jack and lyanna didn't yes yeah
that's right yeah what was it like I
guess different approaches to directing
them so that when people go back and
watch this movie a second time the seeds
are there whether one actor knows and
then the others don't well they all knew
by the time we were shooting yeah oh
okay so yeah by the time but I thought
it was later into production I'm like
how do you do that but that's really but
that how how
the movie views in that new context is
really important to us and it's
something that you know any scene that
those characters are in we spend an
extra amount of time making sure that it
makes sense that the scene makes sense
for it to for it to belong what the
characters are saying what they're
talking about I think one of the only
scenes we yeah we lifted was a scene
where where dermot's standing over the
body of of his daughter and some other
police officers walk in and he's he
tells them to get the out there
like No No One's Gonna touch her body
but but him and it just felt weird if
you were to go back knowing the reveal
like why is she laying there it just
there was there was enough air there
were enough questions sort of in the
repeat viewing of that scene once you
know who the killers are that we were
like do we need it
um so that's that's something to make
sure that it holds up under that level
of a microscope once you know who the
killers are is like a huge thing for us
were there any particular lines of
dialogue that were most tricky to nail
into terms of planting a scene a seed
but not revealing something too quickly
I think the one that jumps out a lot
that I know we talked about when we were
editing and we kind of have fun with it
but it's also they're so well delivered
or there's a scene where Dermot and
Melissa are if you with my family
you die and she's like yeah and you're
like they're just telling you exactly
what's gonna happen in about 45 minutes
like there's also the moment in the
interrogation where he says well I'm I'm
Quinn's father so and I can voucher so I
think we're safe there and the sisters
can look at each other that's one of
those moments that I think was always
like exactly what a Scream movie should
do where it should steer so hard into
who a suspect is that you're like it's
too obvious like there's no way
there's no way that Quinn or Bailey is
the killer both movies the first time
around I figured out some sort of
narrative to make every single person in
that Ensemble guilty and that's great
that's what you're supposed to do all
right now I want to talk about near
death scenes just more broadly how do
you guys figure out how far to push it
with with the violence and the stabbing
and let someone survive in a way that
makes an audience believe that it's
possible believe right yeah
all right
I mean we we you know it's kind of a
two-part answer but we we shoot all of
the violence if it ends up here in the
movie we have it to here and we find
that we calibrate that in the edit you
know we want to make sure we have more
than enough
um
it's that's a big part of it and then
you know again one of the things that we
talked about a lot during this process
was that this should be a secret feel
good movie and we knew we didn't want to
kill these characters like we just
didn't and like and it really might be
us just being softies and being like I
don't know we just love them we love
them as actors we love the characters
like I want to kill them and you know
their obviously conversations about well
should so and so that I should so and so
die and we're like no yeah at the end
it's like the end of the day that core
four thing only works if the four of
them are there at the end of the movie
and but I think in terms of like
calibrating that I think that look we
understand
and and are are fully fully embraced
that we play a little fast and loose
with that I think that that's part of
the fun of these movies and the
heightened reality that they that they
live in and I think to a certain extent
you know movies have movies of
desensitized audiences in that sense
right like we see so many movies now
where there's just an insane amount of
action and create there's a crazy
outcome to those to those sequences and
I think that we we creatively were
comfortable with that we were like cool
let's exist in the lineage of these
movies that are like far into a
franchise where batshit crazy things
happen and then it feels really good
when those characters when those
characters make it out alive and I like
it was just really a conscious choice
for us to sort of steer into the the
wackiness of of that like franchise
Trope at the end it feels really good
from the audience perspective too good
yeah good because it was so hard on the
last one like it's funny like we keep
hearing a lot on this one how it's more
brutal and it's more this and that and
the other when it comes to violence but
like when the last one we killed Dewey
and that's way harder you know like that
so yeah while the mobile might be more
intense than this one like the emotional
kind of violence of the last one I think
is probably worse yeah it's not
something else random question did you
ever consider including scenes in the
movie where the core four was actually
in class at College the the the
monologue was scripted for a minute to
take place in a classroom and um it was
uh when we were in prep we'd found a
cool location but we realized when
looking at the story from a bird's eye
view that there was no time outside
and that for for a city that's so
defined by its exteriors in so many ways
it just felt like we were missing to do
that we would be missing this kind of
key ingredient to the feel the feel of
the movie so we we decided to set it on
the campus instead um which I think
we're really pleased with I think that
that location that's one of our
favorites one of our favorite shoot days
too watching Jasmine take that out for a
walk with
a couple takes and we're like oh wow
we got Frisbee for a couple hours
where I really Panic uh many many quick
specific questions for you Christina so
how they address what happens with their
mother in the movie does that mean that
we are not gonna end up seeing her in
the flesh has she been cut off from
their lives for good it's a great
question I I didn't we just like love
the excitement people have around right
a character that's never been on screen
uh yeah we I don't know I don't think we
have an answer right now I like that you
don't have an answer to that okay I'll
take that I'll take that
um does does Sam dropping the Billy
Loomis mask
signify that
she's kind of moved on or is there a
chance that we'll see him return in the
Visions in the future I think that that
darkness is something that that
character will always have here I think
it's the thing that um we love about Sam
that she's circling a solution or some
reconciliation with that part of herself
but that that's not going to just happen
it's not going to happen that quickly
and we love that that darkness is
something that will and it's not about
overtime and getting rid of it it's
about accepting it yeah but that wasn't
a sign of full reconciliation basically
in all honesty do you know what inspired
the choice to have her kind of you know
turn around on that matter in between
films where we can't necessarily see her
process and make that choice yeah I
think it was just making sure that Gail
was always Gail yeah honestly it was it
was just if we're going to bring if
we're gonna bring that character back
her intro has got to be something super
quick and specific and it has to be just
like definitively Gail weather it's the
most Gale thing possible
who's her new boyfriend and was there
ever another scene with him in it
no I think that was it yeah right what's
there is it there I think in earlier
drafts I feel like there was a there was
there was a foot massage
over over the years working on these two
films have you all ever considered
making a reference to the TV show
there is a reference there is there's
the mask in uh you know the Brandon
James mask is in uh where is the subway
in the subway subway yeah I can't
believe I I maybe I like selectively
miss that
I love that show ultimately I never
liked that mask never liked that mask I
don't know how much you guys have to do
with the marketing but I have I have
very specific two specific questions
from one poster it's one of the ones
that looks like you know Times Square
and it has a big ghost face next door
next to a building or something but it
has stabbed the musical in it is that
something you ever considered
incorporating in the actual movie no but
when we saw that I think we have we'll
have the same reaction
it'd be great it should have checked
with marketing first I know so that that
poster also references
yeah what's up with the mechan which
McKenzies are we talking about Liv's
family or the McKenzies that lives near
the background there's nobody McKenzie's
now I'm just surprised about that too
yeah
field too yeah exactly that's where they
come from so the MacKenzie's dead in
your mind according to that poster I
don't even know
um can you talk a little bit about
building building I want to go back to
the Galaxy and I guess specifically with
this just to focus on one particular one
figuring out how to to build tension in
a moment like that via emotion versus
leaning too much on the violence because
there's something about like the tone of
that scene the pacing of it basically
everything other than the actual like
stabbiness and physical violence of it
that I think is firing on all cylinders
and makes that as effective as I said
earlier I think a lot of that is just
the expectation of Gail's finally going
to have a call with Ghostface I think
that that sort of sets sets the table in
a in a really specific way and then I
think with with Gail specifically you
have a character who's now survived
these movies five times going on six
um and a really smart killer and I think
that watching two characters not only
not only in a physical act
um fighting fighting each other but that
they're also trying to outsmart each
other and they're doing really smart
things that for us is where the best
tension lives is when a character is
like doing the thing that's right but
the the villain is ahead of them or or
like just on their just on their tails
that for us is um is where really great
tension lives especially for characters
like yeah so who's so smart and so
capable like runs and grabs her gun
shoots through the like that's that
whole little run there is one of our
favorite Parts it's also having that
moment with Dewey right before where you
go like you see her get kind of you know
choked up and you go like oh right this
is old
yeah you know and like there's that
moment earlier when Dewey's theme plays
or whatever the Broken Arrow theme but
when Dewey's theme plays when she's
talking to Melissa and that was
something like our editor dropped in and
we were like oh my God that's an
incredible Choice let's not lose
that but it's like making sure that
Dewey is a part of her story moving
forward good choice well and I'll ends
with this one was that last line of hers
always scripted that way was that
something that evolved as you made the
movie how did that come about the Tell
City never tell me yeah that was always
there that was that one that like on the
page even reading it we were like oh God
this is gonna be really this is gonna
hurt and the best in the best way and
though in a way that a Scream movie
should should hurt that's a good line
yeah and Courtney brought it for that
very much that whole is that whole
sequence she brought it above and beyond
anything I ever could have imagined
they're making
there's so much more
yeah
I could go on and on congratulations
thank you thank you